I think you said two for an interview
you did with the Sundance Institute that
you believe that there's no financial
incentive to draw the documentary
process out past a year but obviously
this took what four years to make crime
and punishment yes so I'm wondering how
are you able to put in four years of
time and not run out or did you run out
of money several times and you were able
to apply for grants yeah I mean I think
you know most people working in
nonfiction are finding themselves in
situations they're shooting for years in
order to prove to funders that you know
they have a credible story or a kind of
like a proof of concept on hand you hear
many times you submit you know grant
applications you know and/or to funders
and you know they'll say well come back
when you have more this looks really
interesting and to the point where you
know people want rough cuts of work and
so it's it's it's it's really a
difficult path to try and finish an
independent documentary you know because
you're expending a lot your personal
savings or resources your everybody is
accruing or most people are occurring
tremendous amounts of personal debt on
credit cards and whatnot
and so you know it's it's very hard to
justify but yet you know when you feel
like you are finding yourself in the
crux of a very kind of perhaps
never-before-seen story or access to
individuals that have not you know had
their stories told and it's that's a
very kind of compelling reason to just
find any way possible to continue
shooting so you know luckily I think
being able to freelance in film for
other projects is you know was a
thankfully a way to kind of sustain
myself you know when times were tight
and then ultimately you you know then
ultimately I was able to get funding
thankfully from some really amazing
organizations and individuals
you